US health authorities are exploring
whether to greenlight the emergency use
of gilead antiviral drug Boeing and
Airbus outlined survival plans as the
aerospace industry reals and Tesla's CEO
criticizes lockdown measures after the
company reported a surprise profit in
the first quarter
I'm Shelby Holiday and here are today's
Wall Street Journal headlines another
grim milestone more than 60,000 people
have died of coronavirus in the u.s.
it's more than a quarter of all known
fatalities in the world meanwhile Los
Angeles became the first major US city
to begin offering freak ovid 19 tests to
all residents we would like to see very
quick approvals US regulators consider
granting emergency use approval of the
Gilead drug REM des aveer in Syria scope
it 19 patients if authorized Gilead
would work with the government to ship
the drug to hospitals news of the talks
between Gilead and the FDA follows a
study by government researchers
suggesting that the therapy helped some
patients recover faster it's the latest
in a series of trial data showing
sometimes conflicting results and
causing swings in Gilead stock the
company reports earnings today Boeing
Airbus and their engine supplier General
Electric said they would reduce costs
and cut thousands of jobs and raise
funds in response to the coronavirus
crisis shares of the plane makers closed
up after they outlined survival plans as
they prepare for a long period of
reduced demand that optimistically could
last three years or more
Boeing said it plans to cut jetliner
production and shed 10% of its 160,000
person work force Airbus said it would
quote right-size its business airlines
expect barely 10% of pre-pandemic flying
in the current quarter
get people back there god damn freedom
Elon Musk has called the closure of
Tesla's plant at risk for the economy
equating forced shutdowns to fascism
Tesla's Factory in Fremont California
stopped production in late March to
comply with government orders a
spokeswoman for the County Health
Department didn't respond to a request
for comment Tesla reported a surprise
first quarter profit propelled by strong
demand for its model three but musk
highlighted uncertainty and risks ahead
due to the pandemic